a write-off is a business expense used
to reduce your taxable income okay well
then why isn't it called a tax write-off
it is
it is you can't just buy things for
yourself and write them off
that of course is comedian Eugene Levy
starring as Johnny Rosen the Emmy
award-winning show schitt's Creek Levy
is new Apple TV series The Reluctant
traveler follows him as he explores some
of the world's most unique destinations
Levy admits he's not your typical travel
TV host in fact he says he hates
traveling in this preview we see him
feeding a pair of baby rhinos in South
Africa take a look
they're very large babies
and you pick it up like that excellent
it
he's done excellent that's why we're
giving two
last time I bottled Fed was uh 36 years
ago and the bottle was considerably
smaller and so was my daughter
it's like riding a bike though Eugene
Levy joins us right now good morning how
you doing all right I'm good I used to
think they were the ugliest animals on
the face of the Earth yeah and now I
love them you love them yeah I want to
take I want to take one home yeah so um
you know you said you don't like to
travel
um you're not very adventurous so then
why host a globe trotting travel show
like this well because it wasn't pitch
to me that way it was it was it pitched
to me traveling uh around the world uh
exploring exotic hotels why they came to
me I'm not exactly sure but
it's the first time I've ever hosted and
it's the first time I've been on camera
as myself not in character so there had
to be the very first time really yeah I
don't really like doing that I'm I'm not
really comfortable doing that if I'm
playing a character the further the
Comfort the the further the character is
from Who I Am the more comfortable I am
interesting so but there had to be an
honesty if I'm hosting the show there
had to be an honesty about it of course
and I I because I'm not curious and you
know I'm not an Explorer but they didn't
know that but they found it funny when I
was telling them why I'm not the guy for
the show and then and then after that
they got together and said that's the
show that's the show and that's how it
was pitched to me and I said okay I get
that I get it so clue us into that why
don't you like traveling
I CH you know what I mean I I I it's it
it's there's there's something kind of
anxiety written about the whole thing
from from from packing you know airport
security uh getting through security is
like just is is is crazy you're not
flying
yeah
private jets you must have the wrong
Levy
I've got the wrong Levy there uh no and
then and then and then and then the
sightseeing thing you know it's it's
about at the gut level what do you truly
enjoy yeah when you're sightseeing and
doing nine things in a day
is it truly enjoyable for me no it's
actually not if if I'm honest with
myself well so apparently we're going to
do something we've never done before
we're going to remain seated but we're
going to watch you traveling on this
screen here behind me uh it's a speed
round we're gonna put up clips from the
series uh and then you can just kind of
uh tell us what pops into your head take
us there uh where are we what are you
doing oh uh-huh what's coming into my
head the grandkids right your eyes
closed it's a little nauseous I I can't
I have a thing with Heights so this this
helicopter right so the what comes to
mind uh plunge plunge yeah
so I couldn't look down
um sorry did you lose a poker game to
somebody
did you sign the wrong piece of paper
well you know listen they on this is
actually a great
show to do as long as I can be honest
and say I don't love everything about it
I love the concept I love it you know
what I mean because people identify with
that and there's truth in here yeah well
there there's a lot of Truth in there
and I had to do a lot of revealing about
myself that I really have I've never
done before
um you know so what did you like I'm
curious so I mean you've done the Grand
Canyon you got one coming up you're in a
rain forest of some sort uh yeah that
was really exciting being in a
rainforest that's my thing oh look at
that or more fun with heights yeah yeah
there we go well that was another thing
where they you know they had that out
for me and I and I initially said I
don't know whether I can do that but I I
did well and then you're in the Maldives
somewhere right definition uh Island yes
an island a resort called uh kudadu in
in in and that that was in the Maldives
that's an amazing that is all under
underwater water
um and what's going through my mind
there is leak
it's an underwater to be honest that is
that is an underwater restaurant as part
of a resort on one of the other islands
and we use that for for what they call a
sound bath
um a sound bath yeah so that that was a
something I've never you know done
before and then I slept through most of
it but it was what did you enjoy I mean
what do you enjoy about this in
retrospect since I didn't fall you
didn't crash right no leak you're here
yes that's true well I'm doing I guess
the thing is I'm doing things I'm trying
things yeah it's the idea of forming an
opinion whether you like something or
not but having had the experience of
doing it yeah and before I just wouldn't
want I just didn't want you want to hike
in the Himalayas thanks send a postcard
yeah um I really would rather not be
there right and that's the way I was I'm
not saying I'm proud of it but I'm uh
you know that's that's the shell I was
in and now I can say well at least I'm
trying something I can say been there
done that yeah yeah it's it's a great
concept and there's so many people that
are going to watch this laugh and also
identify with it and it's also
beautifully done the company that that
actually put this together it's it's a
it's a really beautiful show to watch
they did an exceptional job I'll be
living vicariously through you as we
watch every Grimace is captured gorgeous
Eugene Levy thank you so much we
appreciate you man you won the best and
the best one of the most versatile so
much The Reluctant traveler with Eugene
Levy is available now to stream on Apple
TV Plus